يشيع الفلسطينيون في هذه الاثناء في نابلس
جتامين الفلسطينيين الثلاثه الذين
اغتالتهم قوات الاحتلال في البلده القديمه
في مدينه نابلس صباح اليوم
وكانت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه قالت ان
ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين استشهدوا برصاص
القوات الاسرائيليه صباح اليوم خلال
اقتحامها مدينه نابلس
ومحاصرتها منزلا داخل البلده القديمه
وقد اكد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني انا
اربعه اشخاص اصيبوا بجروح خلال عمليه
الاقتحام بينما تعرض 152 اخرون بينهم طلاب
مدارس لحالات اختناق وياتي ذلك في وقت قال
فيه الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قام بتصفيه
ناشطين من حماس وما حسن قطناني ومعاذ
المصري نفذ عمليه اطلاق النار في الاغوار
قبل نحو شهر وذلك بعد حصوله على معلومات
استخبرتيه وصفها بالدقيقه
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه الصور التي نشاهد الان تاتينا
مباشره من نابلس
كما يبدو عمليه التشييع جنازه الشهداء
الذين اختلتهم القوات الاحتلال في المدينه
وسنتابع معكم الاجواء السائده الان هناك
وظروف تشييع وملابثات الشيعه هذه الجنازات
مع مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديري ديري مزيد لتفاصيل حول هذه
العمليه ان كانت هناك اي معلومات جيفارا
وحول ايضا الاجواء السائله الان في نابلس
في ضوء تشييع جنازه الشهداء الثلاث الذين
قوات الاحتلال
يعني لحظه بدء عمليه التشييع للشهداء
الثلاثه قام جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باطلاق النار الكثيف على فتاه فلسطينيه
عند مفرق عين بوسه في شارع حواره الرئيسي
في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منع الطواقم الاسعاف من الوصول
اليها لاكثر من نصف ساعه الان الهلال
الاحمر يؤكد ان اصابه الفتاه خطيره جدا
والطواقم الطبيه تحاول انعاش قلبها بالطبع
قوات الاحتلال تزعم ان هذه الشابه التي لم
تعرف هويتها بعد
حاولت طعن جندي اسرائيلي في منطقه هي اصلا
يوجد فيها العشرات من جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المنتجين
باسلحه وبالتالي يصعد على فتاه بهذا في
مقتبل العمر شابه يعني نستطيع ان نقول
انها شابه ان تقوم بطعن جندي لكن قوات
الاحتلال تقول ان قامت بطعن جندي في منطقه
الكتف وانه اصيب بجراح خفيفه وان الجنود
على الفور قاموا باطلاق النار بكثافه
عليها بالطبع الان المنطقه مغلقه بالكامل
وقلنا قد راينا على مدار الشرك كيف هو
الوضع في حواره الان الى التشييع هنا في
مدينه نابلس تشييع جسامين الشهداء حسن
القطاطني معاذ المصري وابراهيم جبر الذي
اكدت كتائب القسام الذراع المسلح لحركه
حماس انهم من مقاتليها وانهم قاموا بتنفيذ
عمليه الحمراء في الاغوار في خضم شهر
رمضان المبارك وذلك ردا على الاعتداءات
على المسجد الاقصى المبارك ومن وصفوا
بمعتكفين
وحرائر المسجد الاقصى من النساء وكيف
اعتدى جنود الاحتلال عليهم ولم يحترم
قدسيه الشهر الفضيل ولم يحترم قدسيه
اللباس الاسلامي
وبالتالي قوات الاحتلال وعلى لساني
نتنياهو اكد بان
ثمن بالطبع دور القوات الاسرائيليه في
تنفيذ هذه العمليه التي كانت صباحا هذا
اليوم لحظه وصول الطلبه الى مدارسهم
والموظفين الى اعمالهم دخلت في البدايه
قوه خاصه يرتدون بالطبعهم من المستعربين
يرتدون لباس مدني ومن ثم عند اكتشاف امرهم
بدات قوات الاحتلال بتعزيز قواتها حاصره
البلده القديمه لكن كان الحصار الاكبر
داخل منزل كان يتواجد فيه الشهداء الثلاثه
تم اطلاق صواريخ من نوع انيرجا داخل
المنزل وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اكدت ان
الشهداء الثلاثه
الجثمين كانت مشوهه بالكامل وكان يصعب
التعرف على ملامحهم وهوياتهم ولكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو من اعلنه هويات الشهداء على
الفور كذلك اعلن عن تفاصيل العمليه وكيف
تمت وانها تم في هذه العمليه مشاركه اكثر
من 200 جندي من وحدات النخبه وحدات خاصه
للجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا نادرا ما يحدث ان
يتم الحديث عن تفاصيل دقيقه جدا وفقه عدد
من المراقبين فان هذه العمليه هي على ما
يبدو وشكل الاعلان عن تفاصيلها كلها
وكانها رساله للداخل الاسرائيلي من قبل كل
منتقدي نتنياهو والائتلاف الحكومه
الاسرائيلي من الداخل الاسرائيلي ايضا من
مستوطني غلافي غزه الذين انتقدوا كيفيه
الرد على اطلاق الصواريخ قبل يومين من غزه
ردا على
استشهاد الاسير المضرب عن الطعام خضر
عدنان الذي استشهد نتيجه اضرابها عن
الطعام بعد 86 يوما اذا الاوضاع كلها ايله
للتوتر اكثر
اكثر قوات الاحتلال ونقلا عن مصادر للجيش
الاسرائيلي فان الحديث على ان التقديرات
امنيه تشير الى امكانيه وهذا ما يبدو على
الارض توسيع رقعه العمليات العسكريه
تحديدا في شمال الضفه الغربيه ولكن ذلك
ليس بالجديد يبدو انها رسائل سياسيه ابديه
للداخل الاسرائيلي لانه منذ في خلال العام
الماضي راينا حجم المجازر التي ارتكبت
سواء هنا في نابلس او في جنين وباقي انحاء
الضفه الغربيه وما حدث في شهر رمضان
المبارك العام الماضي ولكن في هذا العام
نتحدث عن اقل من يعني ما يقارب الخمسه
اشهر سقط اكثر من 107 شهداء من بينهم
اطفال وفتيات اذا التوتر هو يتصاعد ولكن
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه لا زالت تطالب وتناشد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالضغط على
اسرائيل خاصه وان هناك حديث وليس مؤكد على
ان هناك اجتماع اخر امني فلسطيني اسرائيلي
برعايه مصريه اردنيه امريكيه في شرم الشيخ
نهايه هذا الشهر ولكن كل مره يكون في هذا
الاجتماع يكون فيها توتر اكبر شكرا لك
شكرا لك